mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites tendues après les débordements
de jeudi dernier tendus après les
violences d'hier à sainte-solide
étendues parce que demain quand le
ministère de l'Intérieur s'attend à la
présence d'un millier d'individus
radicaux
les services du ministère de l'Intérieur
anticipent demain des risques très
importants de troubles à l'ordre public
plus de 1000 éléments radicaux dont
certains venus de l'étranger et d'autres
qui étaient présents à Sainte Soline
celui-ci pourrait rejoindre le cortège
parisien et mené aussi des actions dans
les villes de Lyon Rennes Nantes Dijon
et Bordeaux
ces éléments radicalisés
issus de l'ultra gauche et de l'extrême
gauche tant de prendre en otage des
cortèges syndicaux ils viennent pour
casser pour blesser et pour tuer des
policiers des gendarmes leur objectif
n'a rien à voir avec la réforme des
retraites leur objectif est de
déstabiliser nos institutions
républicaines et de pousser la France à
feu et à son bonsoir Philippe bigier
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous députés
modem dorée loi on va repartir
évidemment
de ces déclarations ce soir de Gérald
Darmanin avant la manifestation de
demain je vous donne la parole dans un
instant d'abord Guillaume mis l'individu
radicaux attendus et en face un
dispositif jamais vu depuis le début de
la depuis le début de la manifestation
contre les retraites depuis le début de
manifestation 13000 policiers et
gendarmes à l'échelle à l'échelle
nationale ce record a largement été
battu au moment des manifestations des
jeunes ça a été 80000 et pour les 5500 à
Paris on a déjà atteint 8000 au moment
des manifestations chez jeunes notamment
le 8 décembre 2018 mais depuis
effectivement le 19 janvier depuis qu'il
y a des manifestations revendicatives
contre la réforme de retraite c'est le
dispositif policier le plus
impressionnant au moins à Paris en
nombre de policiers gendarmes mobilisés
parce que à compter de jeudi dernier
c'est-à-dire la neuvième journée
d'action il y a eu un niveau de violence
lors des manifestations qui a monté d'un
cran et qui jusque là on avait 8
manifestations c'était globalement bien
passé le jeudi dernier ça a été plus
compliqué avec la mobilisation des
jeunes qui étaient jugés plus
importantes et qui pourraient doubler
voire triplés nos mains c'est cela aussi
que redoute la préfecture de police de
Paris en fait ce qui est un peu trois
moments difficiles au début de la
manifestation avec le pré-corpège à la
fin au moment de la dispersion puis même
après la manifestation elle-même puisque
ce que l'on a observé jeudi dernier
c'était que une fois que la
manifestation est arrivée à son terme
certains ne se dispersaient pas et vous
voulez rejouer une manifestation après
la manifestation plus tard dans la
soirée ça la préfecture de police de
Paris le redoute aussi Philippe Vigier
on a l'impression on a cercle vicieux
dans lequel on est entré toujours plus
de Black Blocs toujours plus de
policiers en face toujours plus de Black
Blocs etc etc etc comment on sort de ça
une pause mais sur les retraites je me
permets de vous dire une chose tout le
monde a oublié qu'il y a un élément
fondamental dans cette loi c'est la
fameuse clause de revoyure c'est quoi à
cause de revoyure en clair il est prévu
je tiens la commission mixité c'est très
bien ce qui a été écrit dedans que aucun
septembre 2027 regardez où on en était
et on a dit quoi c'est moi qui a écrit
l'amendement qu'on interrogerait les
syndicats qu'on est heureux le Parlement
il y aura un débat au Parlement et qui
avait donc cette possibilité de faire
cette photo 4 ans Philippe Biger
de 2027 vous voyez je suis pas sûr que
ça quand je vais vous répondre très
rapidement est-ce que l'année prochaine
en 2024 on est à 64 ans
non les 64 ans cette loi c'est quand non
mais ça commence
très bien qu'il y a une loi qui est en
train de se dérouler c'est la loi
Touraine la loi telle qu'une labauté
c'est quoi c'est une accélération de la
loi naturelle donc le syndicat on a la
Touraine prévoyait pas 64 ans elle
prévoyait quoi 63 63 ans en 2030
exactement donc en fait on accélère la
voiture dans ce que je dis c'est qu'il
faut entendre naturellement ces
inquiétudes il faut se remettre autour
de la table avec les syndicats par
exemple la faire la pénibilité juste un
mot la pénibilité la transformation des
métiers les plus pénibles c'est
peut-être de dire aussi à ces
travailleurs-là concernés vous partirez
plutôt parce que vous avez des métiers
piliers donc ce dialogue social
l'urgence absolue c'est de remettre tous
les partenaires sociaux autour de la
table et la seconde chose c'est clause
de revoyure faut pas la Belly demain
c'est la première fois dans une voie sur
les retraites on existe
de désescalade il faut trouver les mots
pour la désescalade est-ce que
réellement ce qu'on a entendu de la part
de Gérald Darmanin aujourd'hui en
parlant notamment du dispositif mais
finalement en jetant la thème sur
l'opposition il a parlé d'ultra gauche
puis d'extrême gauche puis on sent bien
le glissement dans dans le langage en
parlant finalement de LFI de la gauche
en général on a entendu également du
côté d'Emmanuel Macron finalement
accusé Jean-Luc Mélenchon et les filles
en général de délai vouloir délégitimer
les institutions est-ce que là il y a
réellement une volonté de désescalade
est-ce que vous pensez réellement que
les mots ont été trouvés pour tenter
d'apaiser les choses
oui il faut trouver les conditions de
l'apaisement et les conditions
d'apaisement c'est toutes les forces
politiques aussi qui a un moment ou un
autre doivent faire un pas les unes vers
les autres vous savez on doit être en
capacité du moins on a un challenge
devant nous c'est assez simple soit on
trouve 4 5 sujets thématiques sur
lesquels on peut élargir les femmes et
les hommes qui disent oui on peut
avancer dans ce pays et ne pas le
laisser bloquer ou alors que se
passera-t-il sans le chaos généralisé on
voit bien que Mélenchon lui cherche à
faire le chaos généralisé ils l'ont fait
à l'Assemblée nationale ils en voulu
bloquer la preuve ils nous ont empêché
de voter vous savez cette fameuse
article sur les 64 ans eux ce qui sont
dans ces stratégies mais un moment ou un
autre ils devront bouger je vais prendre
un seul exemple vous souvenez de du
scandale des EHPAD tel qu'on a pu le
connaître quand même une bombe on a
réussi à faire en deux mois
une mission transpartisanale où il y
avait Caroline Fiat vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée donc il y a des sujets sur
lesquels je vais désamorcer un peu les
questions sur lesquelles on doit être en
capacité
juste une chose par rapport à ce que
vous dites à l'instant et quelque chose
que je ne comprends pas vous dites il
faut se remettre autour de la table etc
etc le président à l'Élysée au
gouvernement on a bien compris qu'on le
voulait pas parler des retraites que
c'est terminé Olivier Véran a dit ce
matin la réforme des retraites est
derrière nous il l'a dit dans le studio
d'à côté face à Pauline de Malherbe donc
le gouvernement veut pas ça autre chose
les syndicats disent attendez nous on
veut parler de ça et on ne veut pas de
cette réforme là donc en réalité on est
toujours bloqué ce soir ma Corderie
d'abord 1 tout le monde serait bien
d'attendre la réponse du Conseil
constitutionnel voyez moi je suis
respectueux des institutions ce sera
alors ça sera le 21 avril on aura les
résultats là-dessus on verra ce qui se
passe 2 à un moment ou un autre avec les
partenaires sociaux il y a peut-être des
modalités sur lesquelles soit réforme du
retraite on peut avancer je vous le dis
très clairement en tout cas nous les
centristes les bonheur que nous sommes
nous
je reviens avec ma classe de revoyure
que vous semblez
oui oui
ça fera pas en sorte que tous les gens
qui seront dans la rue demain rentreront
chez eux si parce que les gens qui sont
dans la rue comme on dit très bien
d'abord on leur a tous dit vous partirez
tous à 64 ans ce qui est un mensonge 6
sur 10 par 64 ans mais oui mais j'ai
bien que la pédagogie était tellement
mauvaise on va dire les choses
clairement qu'elle aurait peut-être
fallu qu'on l'exprime un peu mieux bref
c'est de dire derrière nous qui est dans
le jardin de Elisabeth borne mais moi je
vous dis clairement les choses je trouve
qu'on a été très mauvais sur la
pédagogie voilà j'ai la franchise de le
dire il faut faire son miracule pas des
gens ont compris en fait tout le monde
n'a pas compris les gens ont compris
franchement vous venez avec moi on fait
un micro-trottoir sur la réforme du
retraite il n'a pas 1 sur 10 que vous
explique comment ça marche regardez quel
était sa situation après la réforme
et à la fin vous avez 70% des personnes
dans des centaines qui disent qu'ils
n'en veulent pas écarter chacun de
travailler un peu plus longtemps mais il
faut tenir compte une fois de plus des
métiers les plus difficiles dans
lesquels mais semble-t-il là on doit
trouver les solutions et c'est les
parties sociales regardez moi j'ai
souvent pris ce cas qui est le mien sur
ce plateau j'ai commencé à travailler à
18 ans vous voyez je vous voyiez venir
sur les carrières longues moi je vais
devoir travailler 44 ans celle-ci cette
clause là elle n'est pas réglée va-t-il
falloir attendre 2027 et votre clause de
revoyure pour qu'on pour qu'on égalise
pour tous les 60 enfin les 43 ans le
cotisation par exemple
dans le texte nous avons voté sur les
carrières longues à 50 évoluer les
choses pour tous ceux qui sont partis
avant l'âge de 21 ans vous le savez
comme moi c'est tellement
incompréhensible que tout le monde l'a
pas encore compris que j'avais toujours
44 ans
c'est vrai que dans les tableaux qui
étaient sortis de Matignon j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire ce plateau ils
étaient faux
je suis désolé je reconnais humblement
une fois de plus la communication était
extrêmement on va parler dans une
seconde de la manifestation de demain
avec des jeunes qui sont attendus en
plus grand nombre mais Philippeville il
y a juste une chose vous nous dites on
va attendre sagement la réponse du
Conseil constitutionnel
c'était une première étape dans trois
semaines
vu l'état de tension dans lequel se
trouve déjà le pays dans lequel se
trouve déjà les cortèges avec les images
qu'on a en tête hier avec les crins
qu'on a pour ce qui s'est passé hier et
la semaine dernière avec les craintes
qu'on a pour demain
trois semaines on peut encore se
permettre d'attendre trois semaines vous
pouvez encore vous permettre de dire on
va laisser les syndicats faire une fois
deux fois par semaine des journées de
mobilisation comme cela avec tous les
risques que ça comporte on peut se payer
celui que cela je pense que pour
l'ancien Grenelle social il faut pas 3
semaines je rappelle mais 68 comment ça
s'est passé comme on a été capable en 48
heures de mettre des syndicats autour du
temps mais non il y a une urgence
l'urgence c'est de discuter avec les
partenaires sociaux écoutez moi j'étais
sur un plateau ou qui était du patron de
la CGC et puis la discuté j'ai eu
François Asselin au téléphone il est
presque il y a des choses qu'il faut non
plus regarder avec eux c'est pas trop
tard faut pas me dire d'un côté trois
semaines c'est trop long je ne dis pas
ballon le dialogue social il doit être
ouvert cette semaine il y a un problème
majeur c'est que vous appelez au secours
les syndicats après leur avoir marché
dessus pas vous mais le président de la
République c'est d'ailleurs qu'en fait
vous nous expliquer aujourd'hui qu'il
faut parler avec les syndicats sauf que
le Président de la République lui-même
ne l'a pas fait pendant toute cette
réforme des retraites qu'il a d'une
certaine façon refusé d'entendre leur
revendication lorsqu'il intervient la
télévision il dit qu'il veut tendre la
mort syndic et dans le même temps il
donne une gifle à Laurent Berger devant
tous les téléspectateurs en l'humiliant
inutilement leur rappelant qu'il avait
été les les pièges et point liés par son
congrès aujourd'hui comment vous voulez
renouer ce dialogue avec un président de
la République qui a méprisé les
syndicats et une première ministre qui
est totalement démonétisée y compris par
le Président de la République qui dans
un propos rapporté aurait dit vous
m'avez conseillé de prendre bande
j'aurais mieux fait de prendre votre
train en gros parce que tout le monde
voulait que ce soit bon mais voilà où en
est aujourd'hui si vous voulez votre
situation elle est quand même
politiquement je vous disais que c'est
facile je vous mentirais non mais je
vais vous dire
ça me rappelle 40 ans derrière vous avez
devant lui celui qui était Président de
la Fédération des atomes de France et
c'est ça terminé à l'époque dans le
bureau de François Mitterrand un
dimanche soir à 20h oui la fédération de
quoi pardon j'ai pas compris la
Fédération des atomes de France est
d'accord qui s'appelle Philippe de
Normandie qui nous donne que le père
vient de Normandie oui je le dis pour la
première fois sur ce plateau bon
le blocus on n'était pas écoutés par
dessus puis à un moment ou un autre
président de la République a fait en
sorte que parce que le Président de la
République pas définissons c'est
à mes yeux le père de la nation donc à
un moment ou un autre c'est à lui aussi
un réengager le dialogue donc d'ouvrir
la porte de son bureau quelque chose cet
après-midi il y a eu un échange il me
semble-t-il entre Laurent Berger et puis
Alexis et Alexis Colas donc les filles
du dialogue commencent enfin à se
renouer
citation de Laurent Berger toujours dans
le monde un jour une gifle un autre une
caresse s'il y a question que vous me
posez c'est savoir si je regrette le
fait qu'avec Laurent Berger qui a
toujours été un leader progressiste en
en soit là je le regrette amèrement
mais qui dépasse à l'abri des fautes
dans sa vie politique ou une association
peut faire à manger
ou un autre j'imagine que si il a
demandé à celui qui est le plus proche
de lui de reprendre contact avec Laurent
Berger c'est qu'il a compris qu'il
fallait absolument renouer avec lui et
rapidement Renault avec lui ça veut dire
ça veut dire quoi puisqu'on sait que les
syndicats n'ont pas l'intention de
discuter si on ne revient pas en arrière
sur la réforme parce que globalement
c'est ce qu'il a dit aussi le Laurent
Berger ce qu'il veut c'est une pause et
qu'on ensuite on peut discuter
recommencer à discuter sur la réforme
des retraites et je ne comprends pas
quand vous énumérer un nombre d'erreurs
qui ont été commises je reprends vos
termes de communication notamment par le
gouvernement et quand vous voyez la
contestation massive dans la rue quand
vous voyez l'hostilité à cette réforme
dans les dans les sondages notamment
pourquoi est-ce que il ne serait pas
temps selon vous d'appuyer sur le bouton
pause et de reprendre le dialogue ça
vous aura pas échappé que c'est ce qui
se passe en Israël notamment aujourd'hui
face aussi à une contestation massive
benami Netanyahu a décidé d'appuyer sur
ce bouton pause et de reprendre le
dialogue avec toutes les parties est-ce
que pour vous c'est pas ça c'est pas là
qu'on en est arrivé aujourd'hui en
France
je suis persuadé une chose c'est que les
syndicats autour de la table il ne me
demandait pas les conclusions de la
réunion avec les syndicats avant même
qu'elle ait pu avoir lieu de voir quel
était le chemin qu'on pouvait établir il
y a un chemin à trouver et ce chemin
c'est pas en disant j'arrive avec mes
solutions je veux la peau aussi de rien
ne se passe et les autres disons je ne
bougerai pas un millimètre faut savoir
comment on est capable retrouver ce
chemin et bien il y a des hommes et des
femmes de bonne volonté qui sont
certainement pris à trouver cette
solution on va pas mettre compter sur
nous faire en sorte que les
parlementaires que nous sommes on ne
laissera pas les bras-valents et à
regarder le spectacles de la rue tel
qu'on a pu constater on va pas repasser
le ralenti mais Antonin vous parlez à
l'instant d'Emmanuel Macron vous avez
dit qui n'a jamais commis de faute dans
sa vie politique quelle est la faute
d'Emmanuel Macron non c'est pas le
premier Emmanuel Macron je pense que
avec Laurent Berger c'est dommage qui
est pas eu un lien solide qui est plus
se faire comme si c'était avec d'autres
voilà il y a la vie il y a tout le monde
a dû loupé je suis prêt d'avoir fait des
louper dans ma vie mais personnel et
public mais pourquoi il va à la
télévision pour l'humilier
général ce soir
je fais comme genre
en parler qui vous adore en l'occurrence
est-ce que vous comprenez vous que le
Président de la République haï à la
télévision et donne une gifle en public
elle rend berger
il a eu affronter les gilets jaunes il a
su trouver les voies et les schémas
alors tout le monde disait c'est foutu
il parlera plus à personne il a eu un
courage et c'est d'ailleurs souligné par
l'ensemble des journalistes là la
situation elle est gravissime comme je
le ressens et comme beaucoup le
ressentent et cet état de tension il
faut le faire baisser il faut régénérer
la confiance persuadé que se trouve il
sera trouvé les mots le revenu alors
justement et rapidement je le souhaite
vous voyez plus clair que je vous vous
nous reparlez de l'époque où il avait
réussi avec le grand débat à apaiser en
faisant tout justement tomber la chemise
la chemise reste pardon
que je ne sais pas donc il avait fait
tomber la veste et effectivement il
avait fait ce Tour de France il avait
essayé de d'engager le dialogue mais
aujourd'hui on attend toujours c'est ces
états généraux enfin ce qu'il a ce qu'il
est sorti de ses débats primo donc il
sera compliqué de refaire quelque chose
du même ordre et enfin les syndicats
eux-mêmes le disent aujourd'hui les
leaders syndicaux nous sommes débordés
par notre base qui ne veut plus rien
entendre et on ne on est peut-être pas
toujours aussi aujourd'hui en capacité
de contenir cette volonté de radicalité
donc il ne faudra pas juste calmer les
leaders syndicaux mais véritablement
apaisé et peut-être juste dire
j'ai fauté j'ai foiré pardon j'arrête je
je c'est Noël
j'ai pas tout à fait la même analyse que
vous
pour les gilets jaunes
dans ma circonscription en particulier
on avait fait de nombreuses réunions je
voyais un état violence peut-être aussi
fort que celui qu'on connaît et voyez
pas il est aux abris bon là les causes
sont ils étaient démonétisés par les
gilets jaunes américains
pas demain
les stations c'était plutôt bien passé
avec les services d'ordre des syndicats
confond un boulot formidable et donc je
suis persuadé que revenir à la table de
négociation déjà ça fait des centres de
3 de la température et qu'après et bien
une fois de plus il y a pas de gagnant
il y a pas de perdant j'insiste sur
cette idée qu'il y a un chemin peut-être
un médiateur dont il intervenir tu vois
il faut trouver les moyens d'apaiser les
choses Samuel j'ai l'impression que tu
as des problèmes de cette réforme au
delà de l'opposition qu'elle suscite
c'est que ceux qui la soutiennent dans
l'opinion publique la soutiennent
faiblement qu'elle trouve pas de relais
d'opinion et je me demande si on
n'arrive pas aux limites du macronisme
en tant qu'idéologie qui comme c'est un
mouvement en fait un peu une classe
sociologique composée en partie en tout
cas les lectorat macronistes qui va de
Elizabeth borne qui était quand même la
chef de cabinet de Ségolène Royal
Darmanin Sarkozy donc en fait on ne sait
pas ce que c'est le macroniste personne
ne sait il y a c'était une
identification sociologique qui
présidait votre Macron plutôt qu'une
adhésion idéologique donc aujourd'hui
le gouvernement ne peut pas fédérer peut
pas susciter d'enthousiasme parce que on
sait rien en fait Isabelle borne et
Darmanin on sait pas ce qu'ils veulent
on ne sait pas pourquoi il gouvernent
ensemble d'ailleurs donc est-ce que vous
pensez pas qu'on arrive à la limite de
ce que vous pouvez faire Macron et qu'il
est temps de revenir au clivage droite
gauche classique
à droite et une à gauche
une avec Éric verse et Nicolas Sarkozy
l'autre avec François Hollande et
marisolles Touraine c'est quand vous
êtes ministre en charge des retraites
regardez derrière vous il y a plus grand
monde pour vous soutenir dès que ça
c'est difficile pardon et lorsque la rue
commence à s'animer fortement une fois
le plus elle a été très mal expliqué
une fois de plus par exemple
on a été incapable d'apporter les vrais
chiffres pour ces fameux amélior 800 000
personnes qui allaient avoir leur
retraite revalorisée parce que moi ce
qui m'attriste c'est pour ça que je me
suis beaucoup impliqué dans ce texte les
femmes où il y avait vraiment des écarts
absolument insupportables par rapport
aux hommes je dis pas qu'on sera tout
complet on aura pris trois très belles
mesures ça c'est complètement passé sous
les radars personne n'en parle les
seniors tous des larmes de crocodile sur
le fait qu'entre quatre ans un sur trois
travail là il y a des mesures un peu
fortes tout est passé sous les radars le
seul truc c'était les 64 ans le seul
truc mais tout le monde a oublié qu'avec
la loi Touraine vous le disiez madame
tout à fait tout à l'heure c'était 63
ans en 2030 et c'est pas pour ennuyer
les Français c'est parce qu'il faut
travailler un peu plus parce que on a
des problèmes budgétaires il faut bien
le comprendre
ce qui se passe à Bruxelles on gagne pas
tous les combats il y a les Allemands
nous ont encore des espions vous savez
sur le nucléaire
nous a expliqué que nucléaire n'était
pas suffisamment énergie décarbonée et
que c'était pas stratégique donc la
France n'est pas en situation de force
et donc on devait aussi faire passer un
signal là -dessus mais sauver le système
de retraite c'est sauver le répartition
elle serait plus simple de dire on
laisse filer les déficit public et puis
après chacun fait sa retraite
complémentaire comme dans d'autres pays
européens aux États-Unis aux économisez
des milliards
cette fracture et toute cette
contestation pour 10 milliards d'euros
d'économiser et franchement la grande
réforme des retraites d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'experts disent qu'il va
falloir en faire une assez rapidement
notamment dans chaque ancienne Nicolas
Sarkozy donc en réalité votre effort
elle est petite réformes quoi
vous vous êtes figé une fois de plus
d'avoir ces 18 milliards mais on fait 7
milliards de retard mais on compense
mais quand vous donnez par exemple pour
les congélateurs de ce qui pour les
enfants nés avant 2012 c'est un détail
technique qui n'était pas calcu dans le
calcul retraite des femmes c'est
simplement 900 millions d'euros cumulés
d'ici 2030 mais aussi ça n'intéresse
personne quand vous été un milliard
d'euros sur la table pour les métiers
pénis pouvoir comment on fait de
l'adaptation c'est aussi un peu d'argent
qui est mis sur la table donc elle a été
très mal expliquée elle a été assez mal
relayée il faut le dire incapable
d'apporter les précisions à un moment ou
un autre et puis
à côté ça vous avez pu voir que vous
n'êtes pas là
en tout cas j'étais à la commission
d'expérité mais c'est intéressant parce
qu'on a pu voir aussi que vous voyez des
hommes et des femmes pourtant les
insoumis étaient là les socialistes
étaient là il y avait pas quand même des
voies éteintes au contraire les voix
animées on était capable de débattre ma
petite panneau et c'est à 2 mètres de
moi on a été capable tu fais les Viger
et juste une chose quand on voit la
question qui s'affiche sur l'écran et
maintenant comment on gouverne comment
pardon et maintenant on gouverne comment
il y a eu de nouvelles réunion
aujourd'hui autour du président de la
République autour de la première
ministre etc on nous explique désormais
que Elisabeth borne a 3 semaines pour
des définir un nouveau contrat de
méthode qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
contrat de méthode c'est simple le
contraire de ce qu'on affiche à présent
ah
ça veut dire
quoi
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quoi non
mais je vous dis à les choses assez
simplement
personne que nous sommes pas dans une
majorité absolue
comment vous faites il faut que vous
ayez chercher des hommes et les femmes
qui sont prêts à vous soutenir sur les
textes donc comment vous faites dans ces
cas-là et bien vous allez en amont des
têtes qu'est-ce qu'on fait demain pour
la santé mais on peut pas dire on fait
ça à l'intérieur uniquement trois
groupes de la majorité va chercher les
socialistes on va chercher des
républicains on va chercher d'autres
femmes ou d'autres hommes qui sont prêts
à les jeux prendre un exemple l'accès
aux soins vous savez que c'est un sujet
absolument dramatique dans ce pays
est-ce que vous entendez beaucoup parler
d'un groupe transpartisan ou d'une
proposition de loi transparisane que
nous avons monté avec des communistes et
socialistes des insoumis des centristes
des républicains on est en train de
faire le tour de France mais pour
l'instant il y a pas eu beaucoup
j'avais compris que quand Elisabeth
borne est arrivé nous a parlé des
majorités de projets c'était déjà ça
donc il semblerait qu'elle ait échouer
est-ce que c'est la bonne personne pour
porter à nouveau ces questions de
majorité de projets
je suis pas sûr du président
la nouvelle feuille de route c'est
d'établir il y a quelques chantiers sur
la santé sur l'école par exemple le
grand âge je pense cet exemple c'est
vraiment dans le Bien vieillir c'est pas
un petit sujet non ça aurait dû être
prioritaire même avant la réforme des
retraites je suis d'accord avec vous
mais pas sur la gauche on nous expliquer
qu'on allait faire le grand âge qu'on
allait s'en occuper et on n'a jamais
rien fait
Sarkozy nous parler du 5e risque
dépendance déjà
et là reconnaissant qu'Emmanuel Macron
avec à l'époque à newsor il s'est posé
les fondations et Brigitte bourguignon
de ce qu'on appelle le grand âge
maintenant le problème c'est qu'il faut
mettre un peu d'argent dedans vous savez
le véhicule législatif qu'on a choisi
une proposition de loi donc on a fait le
PPMC on a pensé à l'école le plus petit
multiple commun alors que c'est une
grande loi et je suis persuadé que le
grand âge croyez-moi aussi de gauche de
droite du Centre ou d'ailleurs
on est capable de s'y retrouver on verra
ça mais avec ça on aura toujours pas
résolu le problème des retraites j'en
reviens à la manifestation de demain 10e
journée de mobilisation avec dans les
notes des services de renseignement
Pauline Simonet une petite ligne qui
clignote depuis la semaine dernière la
présence de plus de jeunes c'est pas
encore complètement massif mais s'il y
en avait beaucoup plus déjà la semaine
dernière et ce que disent des services
de renseignement c'est qu'ils devraient
demain être encore plus nombreux dans
les cortèges
de renseignement ils ont noté qu'il y
avait une partie de la jeunesse qui
s'était pas consentie concernée
jusqu'ici et qui s'est fortement
mobilisé le lors du 28 mars lors du 23
mars pardon et qui seront de nouveau
dans la rue le 28 mars tout d'abord pour
bloquer leurs établissements une
centaine de lycées avait été bloqué le
23 mars il devrait être encore plus
nombreux demain et puis surtout d'après
ce que dit les services de renseignement
il pourrait être deux à trois fois plus
nombreux demain dans les cortèges il y a
eu des appels au blocage qui ont été
donnés pour l'instant il a pas encore
énormément mais ça devrait être très
nombreux également demain c'est ce que
dit notamment la présidente de
l'Université
on ressent énormément d'établissements
mobilisés avec des assemblées générales
qui ont lieu ou qui ont eu lieu ce matin
sur la quasi entièreté des universités
françaises et ce qu'on voit aussi c'est
que finalement depuis l'annonce du 49-3
tous les soirs il y a des jeunes qui
sont mobilisés dans la rue dans les
mobilisations intercentuelles et on
attend encore extrêmement de monde
demain énormément d'assemblées
généralement encore lieu demain des
blocages universités sont prévus demain
également et on voit déjà en fait
finalement des jeunes qui commencent
déjà à se préparer pour la date de
demain qui à notre sens va être
historique va être un point culminant en
fait de cette mobilisation alors on l'a
entendu ce qui a mobilisé fortement les
jeunes c'est le 49-3 ça a été comme un
électrochoc mais aussi on en parle
beaucoup du côté de la jeunesse ce sont
ces violences qualifie violences
policières qu'on a vu notamment à
sainte-solide mais également pendant la
journée ça devrait mobiliser encore plus
les cortèges les jeunes dans les cortège
demain
question Guillaume farde quel problème
est-ce que ça pose aux forces de l'ordre
une fois que vous avez dans les cortèges
des rangs beaucoup plus massifs du côté
des jeunes ça pose plusieurs problèmes
d'abord les jeunes se confond pas
toujours
aux consignes de l'intersyndical des
obligations syndicales et des services
d'ordre des organisations syndicales
c'est plus diffus c'est ça ce catégorise
moins facilement un jeune en
manifestation
l'Inter syndical c'est assez facile
c'est assez balisé c'est des bus qui
convergent notamment vers Paris ou vers
les grands centres urbains chacun a son
syndicat ses repères ces banderoles ces
ballons et ça défile et ça se passe
globalement plutôt bien mais la moyenne
d'âge est plus âgée chez les jeunes
c'est plus insoumis on va dire
moins volontiers sur des moins
volontiers aux injonctions
de parcours de marins il y a un
itinéraire principal pour Paris je pars
et qui va de la place de la République à
la place de la Nation en empruntant
boulevard Voltaire il y a un parcours
secondaire avec qui voilà on va
s'afficher à l'écran qui emprunte la
place de la Bastille donc c'est d'abord
de deux deux deux itinéraires à gérer et
puis en pré-corpège il y a toujours les
éléments les plus perturbateurs qui se
positionnent devant si Laurent a été
grossi par la présence de de jeunes qui
ont envie pour certains devoirs pour
d'autres de sexe dans dans hélas le
recours à la violence je pense c'est
plus compliqué à gérer tout de suite et
cela c'est au début à la fin ça pose des
problèmes parce que la dispersion je dis
a été plus compliqué que les 8 fois
précédentes et enfin je dis il y a une
manifestation après la manifestation en
tout cas il y a eu un mouvement plus
violent d'ailleurs que que le cortège
lui-même qui a eu lieu en soirée et ça
aussi c'est redouté du côté c'est le
cauchemar des forces de l'ordre
fatalement c'est le cauchemar mais c'est
que un un syndicat qui défile c'est
relativement balisé vous vous parlez
avant vous parlez pendant les services
d'ordre le téléphone de jusqu'au la
police lui-même et ça arrive à manœuvrer
les jeunes on les a vu à partir de du
jeudi de l'annonce du 49.3 et surtout du
vendredi ça se déclare pas ça ça se
réunit depuis les réseaux sociaux ça
joue volontiers aux jeux du chalet ou
Pacman c'est la version plus moderne il
y a un côté attrape-moi si tu peux dans
les rues de Paris et toi
Pacman mais c'est pas mais cela étant
c'était pas que des jeunes liés à
l'ultra gauche on a beaucoup entendu
l'ultra gauche l'extrême gauche etc mais
il y avait pas que ça dans les rues de
Paris en soirée il y avait des jeunes
qui pour certains d'entre eux vous
voulez voir vous voulez vivre quelque
chose alors c'est quelque chose d'assez
violent soit incendié les poubelles ou
dégradés de mobiles urbain on a fait
mieux en terme de de motif de
mobilisation mais certains venaient
aller un coup sur réfugiant à la cage
d'escalier du voisin du copain puis
repartait et il y avait quelque chose
qui a enlevé cet ordre là et donc
c'était pas faut pas le caricaturer
nécessairement le politisant Alex c'est
est-ce que ça
[Musique]
c'était à l'époque où vous en souvenez
des Voltigeurs qui ont tabassé un jeune
homme rue Monsieur le Prince ça avait
conduit justement à une forme de pose là
pour le coup et de mes coups pas
collectif on se pose encore aujourd'hui
la question du maintien de langue est-ce
que vous êtes choqué par les images que
vous voyez aujourd'hui dans les
manifestations sur les maintiens de
Nantes d'abord je vous dis les choses
les policiers du gendarmes font un
boulot formidable
on est aussi en première ligne
deuxièmement on a vu des images oui j'ai
vu des images des deux côtés moi j'ai
des images aussi manifestants quand vous
allez manifester ça m'est arrivé de le
faire vous voyez je pars pas avec des
boules de pétanque avec des arbalètes
avec des c'est ça j'ai encore des objets
coupants ça n'existe pas ça manifestait
comme ça après j'ai vu que Gérald
Darmanin avait immédiatement saisi
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale pour savoir si oui non il y a
des choses qui avaient été commis s'il y
a eu des premiers gaz il fera les
sanctionner mais ne jetons pas le propre
sur l'ensemble les forces de gens police
d'ailleurs vous savez il y a un député
un collègue qui s'appelle Boyard vous
connaissez tous menacé de morts que vous
savez mais lui qui m'aime qui nous dit à
l'Assemblée nationale la police tu il
est protégé par la même police voilà ce
qui se passe alors pas l'oublier donc
les images je les ai vu mais j'ai vu
aussi votre confrère journaliste
vous avez vu le témoignage qui a été le
sien d'expliquer qu'il a mis la violence
des manifestants j'ai encore un vieux
souvenir qui a d'une trentaine d'années
vous en souvenez peut-être parce qu'en
France on ne peut plus rien faire les
écologistes intégrist qui avait dérapé
c'était pour construire un barrage sur
leur rivière l'Allier oui ou pendant 10
ans ils ont fait un siège permanent et
ils ont réussi à faire en sorte donc oh
non avant c'était de l'arzac oui c'est
vrai vous avez pas oublié non plus donc
en fait je ne comprends pas cette
écologie intégrée je ne l'accepte pas
oui l'écologie oui bien sûr le chauffeur
climatique c'est l'affaire de tous mais
l'intégrisme et la violence t'as pas de
place comme le dit Gérald Darmanin
ils ont brûlé des véhicules de
gendarmerie ils nous explique samedi
soir faut arrêter les émanations de gaz
à effet de stratégie
une chose on parlait d'elle à l'instant
Elisabeth borde je sais pas si elle
regarde 22h max mais en tout cas
visiblement elle a eu la sortie de la
nécessité de clarifier les choses ce
soir et elle publie une série de huîtres
regarder le président Emmanuel Macron
elle a publié à l'instant elle m'a
demandé de bâtir un programme et de
gouvernement et un nouveau programme
législatif parlementaire élu locaux chef
de parti partenaire sociaux je
consulterai dans les prochaines semaines
tous ceux qui veulent agir pour le pays
mon CAP apaiser le pays et rassembler
les bonnes volontés accélérer les
réformes en proposant des mesures aux
effets rapides et concrets pour les
Français et elle termine en disant ces
consultations débute avec les présidents
de groupe les rapporteurs généraux les
présidents de commission
plein emploi un industrialisation ordre
républicain écologie santé éducation
nous sommes attaques c'est formidable 3
tweets pas en haut de la réforme de
retraite
tout à l'heure d'une nouvelle méthode
surtout il y a un éléphant au milieu de
ce studio et au milieu des débats
politiques depuis des semaines la
première ministre on lui donne un
nouveau cap etc rebâtir une majorité il
y a pas un mot sur la réforme des
retraites
ce soit la fille a pris une réunion qui
a eu à Matignon ce sera 20h quel
d'ailleurs le président
Jean-Paul Mattei persuadé que un moment
ou un autre avec les partenaires sociaux
on va parler de retraite ce qui est
intéressant
répondre avec cette même méthode vous le
disiez vous-même se relier de fait juste
après les élections comment imaginer que
une fois que les élus certains d'entre
eux l'ont dit ils sont sentis piétinés
méprisés comment imaginer que ça va
pouvoir fonctionner
vous savez François avait une phase
dramatique un jour sur le cheval on a
tout essayé vous souvenez moi je pense
qu'on a pas tout essayé sur la
construction politique et faire en sorte
justement qu'on sort du sentier battu
dans lesquels nous étions depuis de
longues semaines sur l'incompréhension
capuche créer d'associer plus les
citoyens je vais prendre encore un
exemple il y a le CNR qui a été inventé
le consignation leur fondation santé non
mais ça vous montre les
dysfonctionnements que nous vivons
excusez-moi je vous donne un point de
détails
le 4 avril dans quelques jours on
discute à l'Assemblée la veille et c'est
la limite pour déposer les amendements
sur ce même texte mais on marche sur la
tête ça marche pas
contribution
qui a annoncé demain parce que c'est
intéressant elle donc à l'annonce comme
pour se rasséréner pour montrer que la
confiance du président qui a lancé les
consultations et notamment elle dit les
gens qu'elle va réunir demain donc ça
c'est donc le programme du gouvernement
nouveau programme législatif on savait
faire voilà c'est consultation des buts
avec les présidents de groupe les
rapporteurs généraux et les présidents
des commissions de la majorité pour
servir nos priorité en acte donc ce sont
des invités qui sont institutionnels qui
ne peuvent absolument pas se dérober à
cette réunion mais qui ne sont pas les
interlocuteurs qui sont des
contradicteurs ça n'a rien à voir avec
des réunions syndicales ou des
consultations syndicats c'est le lundi
on arrive au bout merci en tout cas
d'avoir été regardé demain 10e journée
de mobilisation bien sûr ce sera à
suivre en direct sur BFMTV regardez tout
au long de la journée retraite jusqu'où
ira
la colère merci à tous les 6 de m'avoir
accompagné ce soir on sera là évidemment
demain merci Philippe obligé d'être venu
autour de la table de 22h max c'est
d'avoir été l'avocat de la majorité ce
soir
[Musique]